hello everybody and welcome to part 4 of
let's play penumbra overture oh when we
last left off I got my ass handed to me
by a puzzle you should see the puzzles
oh hi I've really beat it up but it just
got me in its sucker punched me
yeah no no no no no no no no no no no oh
right oh yeah mine this exit Bam Bam
nothing
uh okay explosive all right I'll find
the explosive I'll beat the doggies face
in oh that sounded mean I'm sorry for
saying that where's the explosives aha
so the this uh uh doggie don't even try
it doggy don't even try it
I am so not in the mood that puzzle just
made me so mad ah doggy ah are you going
doggy where you going where you going
doggy
yeah that's what I thought that's what I
thought pray to you yeah where are you
ah yeah that way well Oh doggy
tanti but oh yeah I remember that from
before must be stupid
okay all right
we're cool cool doggie ah I see your
butt don't make me shove this barrel off
your butt I will I'll do it ah it sound
like a lion dead zombie lying dog hybrid
it's 50 miles to the gallon
ha ha ha hybrid human my show okay what
we got here
ha yeah take that whole did it yep
that's what I thought
fuse ok right string just long enough to
make a fuse out of what are you talking
about oh I get it
wait no I get it ah yeah oh yeah
BAM what all you stupid you're stupid
oh there's a few I need some gunpowder
ah gunpowder it's stupid it's a box of
10 it's a barrel of TNT
oh oh not the dog is that like the dog
oh right something puzzle now give me my
reward my eternal reward
oh oh hello Oh nope nope oh okay
this puzzle again is not going to beat
me why because I am so smart I ate my
Wheaties this morning can hear box I
don't need you barrel probably
impossible to get you out there anyway
oh I just need to stop this from
slipping so put this here nice and
gentle get down on my knees and pray to
Jebus oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah haha
alright oh yeah oh so smart
Oh explosive just what I need aha yeah
it is more like it get open oh oh ah get
stir yeah ah yeah oh yeah I'm so strong
yeah yeah dynamite yeah Donna must
yep why would I even look at it
ah you don't make any sense guy John is
that what I called you I don't care
not quite right uh what do I do
oh I just wasted dynamite why did I do
was it the only reason I came here that
was the only thing in here why the help
what why I got bombs aah
all right another dynamite okay I'm not
gonna waste this one all right this
can't have been the only thing that
puzzle was like level 99 hardness aah
aah okay fine fine yeah Oh jot it down a
note okay
no D note no nope oh okay oh no where's
our nowhere where note I don't see you
know shut your lying to me
John John stop lying to me such an
[ __ ] there's ripped off by me who's
so mad
huh right well I guess I got no
gunpowder gunpowder oh I don't have a
gunpowder get the Gunpowder out do it do
it
uh oh yeah there's a dog you don't be
running we're yet Pucci ah their yard so
not in the mood not in the mood this
puzzle should not be taking this long
yeah you're a puppy
oh is it gunpowder try nitro to lean I
knew that Tolu totally dicey up the fuse
ah why don't you use it nope nope nope
great oh I didn't notice these AHA cuz
I'm so smart anyway oh uh uh oh yeah you
so you're blind as a bat dog oh you
didn't even see me even I would have saw
me oh I'm embarrassing myself on the
Internet
oh this is a shame oh this is a right
bloody shame Oh what am i doing what am
i doing ah yeah dog I'm not even scared
I wasn't scared before but now I'm even
less scared ah
explosive workshop are there two places
am I just being a [ __ ] workshop is that
way who's the office is the office NBC
oh okay
fine I'll go back to this place one last
time one last time that's it that's the
last one oh all right
fine shovels OH
shovel tell me out of yourself
Oh what is this was this was this I
don't care
use it for something oh I don't even
know I don't know oh I don't know ah I
already was it conferred you long time
ago
oh I started making stupid movies about
video games oh no he's gonna watch my
video oh because I'm being terrible uh
oh no way no holes too small
Oh [ __ ] I will there we go
[ __ ] you ah fine
Oh God nevermind alright I'm better um
oh sorry I had a temporary lapse in
smartness I was really getting to me
alright let's get this over with alright
bring it on Brandt Jobe barrel jump leet
alright
360 spin oh yeah again Oh a fail oh yeah
win oh right
shut up puppy no cares about you
[Applause]
oh yeah all right
kaboom aah
Oh fine
aah no 360 fail win
shut up doggie no one likes you
now right
Oh Oh got to take cover ok have a way
the [ __ ] over here
Oh bondic right Oh No Oh [ __ ] yeah you
doc you didn't even hear that you sued
death all right let me through when I
look back I can't think what spurred me
to go deeper into the mine maybe it's
cuz you couldn't get out
arrogance knows cuz you've trapped
radicular facing adversity no you were
trapped Oh better off starving yeah
right okay alright I have to pause it
here thanks so much for sticking with me
through that I know it was a complete
embarrassment and I'm sorry about that
but stick around part 5 will be coming
shortly bye-bye